well the chief executive is Sep James
and he joins me nice so I thought
nuclear winter descended on the high
street why you guys bucking the trend I
think the death of the high street has
been has been overestimated I think
we're still in a world where consumers
are definitely canny they want great
deals and and we think our job is to
make sure they get them but I mean
obviously you've lost some of your
competitors in recent years the likes of
common phones4u have have turned up
their toes has that been a significant
benefit for your is that in the rearview
mirror now yeah it's very much in the
rearview mirror I mean what we we have a
very competitive market we've got across
a lot of online players and we still
have a number of others who operate in
this space and I think that what
customers say to us is there is that if
we are on the money and we provide great
service they will continue to shop with
us and so far that's been really working
well I'm you closed around 100 UK nine
installs during the last 12 months it is
are there more store closures to come no
we think we're in all the right markets
now what we've been doing is taking
where we had a single retail park with a
Curry's and a PC world we've been
building a new shop which has both
carries an PC well but also carphone
warehouse inside and that's really
worked well we've been able to take a
lot of space out of our estate but at
the same time grow sales so it's a kind
of magic trick yes that's a really big
debating point I mean there's an awful
lot of talk still about business rates
and I mean there are increases coming
down the pipeline I mean ultimately
isn't that connote erode your
competitiveness against the likes of
Amazon and AO comm yeah in the grand
scheme of things course business rates
is quite a small expense for us but but
we we need to make sure that everything
is done to - to ensure that everybody's
playing on a level playing field and and
you know we're certainly encouraging and
helping people think through what what
the right model for that is but at the
moment I think we seem to be doing okay
are you still concerned about Amazon and
all are they just one of many other
competitors that you face yeah we have a
lot of competitors and we worry about
all of them and particularly I worry
about you know where do I think
competitors are doing something that we
ought to be copying and where do we
think we do things that our competitors
don't do and I think those are the you
know in it you wanna have more of the
latter and less of the former
interesting no we were talking just now
about Tesco and clearly it's a business
going through transition I mean once
upon a time people like them were
nibbling away at your market share they
less of a threat now well we're actually
opening a couple of
inside Tesco in the next few months and
it'd be interesting to see how those
those go because you know we think that
Tesco customers do like our products and
we're really glad that in those two
stores at least they'll be buying them
from us the overall state of consumer
confidence said I mean clearly now we're
in a position where off a couple of
years of wages outpacing inflation we're
now in the reverse position how worried
are you about the robustness of
consumers yeah I think so far so good I
mean we certainly people seem to be
buying election goods from us okay and I
think we seem to be you know chugging
along just fine but we'll we know we've
got our antenna twitching - if there is
any change we need to react very quickly
and to be even more on the market and
make sure that we're all over it but so
far so good
could conventional wisdom would suggest
that someone selling big ticket items
like you would be really quite
vulnerable if consumer spending takes a
serious downturn yes as I say so far so
good and and I think the main thing is
to make sure that you're doing the best
you possibly can to give great prices
and you know we let people compare
prices and they go on our website we
show our competitors prices we want to
make sure that everybody feels really
comfortable that that they're getting
the best possible deal from us and and
and that's been that's been a good
strategy thus far what about the drop in
the pound over the last 12 months
clearly a lot of the goods that you sell
are imported how how you are you pass
them on those price increases yet yeah
we're a bit different to other
industries so you know if you take
bananas or something a banana is much
the same from one year to the next our
products change quite a lot and our
products are very deflationary so for
instance in March 16 we launched an LG
high-definition TV 55 inch TV it cost
$17.99 today you can buy that same TV
for $7.99 so the rate of deflation of
our products is enormous Lee quick and
Dwarfs any inflationary impact and in
terms of the individual markets in which
you're operating I think I'm right in
saying if one market showing most of
them apart from mobile this year was no
I think even in mobile now in in the
last in the third quarter last year we
lost a little bit of Sharon in post
player land we've got that back now so
we actually gained you know touchwood
we've gained share in all segments in
all markets for this full year okay and
we've got six months to go till
Christmas we have been a big seller
well who knows I mean last couple of
weeks it's been fans we sold 40,000 fans
of the last couple of weeks as
as England swelter dangling Scotland's
Wheldon under and an untimely son and
we'll have to see what comes out I think
PC gaming is going to be very hot this
year okay well what's your space you
heard it here first except James started
joining me could see